so here uh we'll do part four of video
Gateway Aikido video 15.
okay so uh
part four let's look at keyhon go to
kihon
and understand it
in such a way that is not violating
anything we did in uh videos part one
part two and part three so we're not
going to clash and we're not going to
stop him
so generally we're going to think in
again in yin and yang but generally uh I
would have a Mimi and a 10 con variant
okay for me to do an edemy variant of a
kihon I have to catch the strike in its
Yin phase
for me to do a 10 con variant of the
kihon I have caught this strike in its
young phase you and I won't mix the two
okay so for example if he's doing
yokumin
Uchi remember that strikes are closer so
don't start a million miles away okay so
when he comes in I am not going to go I
caught it on the young you see that
would be a young young Clash so instead
I have to catch it on the yin then it'll
work okay so if we look at his stride
his strikes coming up and here's where I
should already have contact and when he
flares the elbow or the hand comes out
you see that to give him his kesa angle
that is the yin movement that I use uh
to take his body off balance okay we're
gonna do it and see what it was like
because we have had so many Gateway
requests that we here haven't done
suareza and we started to do a lot of
suareza so we're gonna do it
is actually harder so when if it works
here it's gonna work in tachiwasa again
okay so as he comes up that is when I've
done the movement okay and then his
commitment carries through
and then you won't have that uh Yang
Yang Clash however
you have to use the two spirals we
always refer to so you have the inward
spiral
and you have the outer spiral
you're going to do the inward spiral
here
it's gonna I'm not gonna go here like
that
once I make contact I do the inward
spiral and when I move my body I'm on
the outside of the inward spiral and it
creates
a turning of his initial or inertial
movement forward so I'm not going here
even if it was on the yin move I'm not
doing that
I make contact and I do the spiral
and we're here
contact on the inside
it's different
you can say it's different it sounds
different it feels different there's no
connection
so once you get there that's where it'll
come back up that's where you would have
all your
technique or whatever you wanted to do
okay so again
boom
I'm doing this inward spiral
but it's in relation to that
and it's going this way
and my body does it
okay so our simple throw here is hold
the elbow palmio that faced ad me off
the line of attack you'll make
connection all right let's try it
Hugo I'm gonna talk okay here it's not
you it's the whole world does this so
you see he's gone from the inside to the
outside he cuts down that that's what
the whole world sees okay
and that's just not it okay so if you
come in faster and harder with more
inertial movement forward you can see
the Clash do you see okay it's just most
your Aikido people are all super nice
and stuff like that
questions don't go standing okay
so I I'm I am doing this
there's your movement ah right only I'm
gonna move to the side
excuse me got it and then I'm gonna turn
his body with that movement do you see
that's basically it and then what once
he goes cool then that's where I can
come over the top okay
so I again I'm not going here
I'm actually going here
but my body's moving there
you see so if you wash my hand
wash my hands
you see
now watch my hand
you say it's going this way only my body
goes cool
okay so you gotta trust the inner spiral
but it's the IQ adhesion too okay so
boom I'm good he's gonna make contact
and I am
going to do the inward spiral
from there
boom this way but I moved
okay
try it again
okay so even even my destiny here are
having problems with this
um
Energy's coming this way
but you ain't eat meat you see so you
have to ID me on the yin movement that
makes sense
but it doesn't mean now I just get to
slam the dude because you won't you'll
what you'll do is you'll isolate the arm
okay so what happens I go like that you
see his arm disconnected from his body
you see that I don't have his body
what generally what you're what you're
choreographed UK does is when you
disconnect the on they'll turn their
body you see well if he could turn
himself then I didn't have his Center
you see that so that's not a solution
so same thing as I'm here I have this
whole body and the faster and harder he
strikes the easier it'll be to do
because there's more energy for me to
turn back around do you see that so on
that one you actually got a little
Airborne I'm gonna see what he wants a
technique you see that when so what
happens is I go here
eventually this movement is going to
turn him around do you see and now which
way is he going
that way
so once you once I feel it go that way
wants energy I turn the energy
then I can enter that's where I cap the
elbow that's where I throw this strike I
already turned him around does that make
sense so it's not that I'm going here
stopping him
I turn him and then he's he's here now
for me to do young movement you see that
okay
okay so we we just said it so that's
what I always say he should already be
going the other way by the time I enter
if he's not going the other way until I
enter that would be a young young Clash
okay so I already turned it that way he
was already falling that way and now I
aim a falling body okay
um
so if I I go to catch it but I'm a
little late that's where you have your
yields okay so another common one is
you're going to do
all
do you see but now you're stopped him
and now he's not going the other way
until you make him go the other way that
would be incorrect
so colloquial Hall is going to pass from
the heels to the adhesion
to this adhesion so this time goes here
and together it moves
womb this adhesion to this adhesion so
he's not there I don't want to go here
but I bring him around and once he
touches that that's where
[Music]
thank you
so if you were standing
here to there
this way same thing no keep them going
around we'll do that one
oh there it is cool not there I gotta do
one more little Loop
boom here boom there then
oh
don't get greedy
and go here
passing from there to here
to there
[Music]
back to seating
okay let's try
whoa same came up on that last then
trying to do it okay so my elbows here
and I'm gonna on its on this connection
you think on that adhesion
I'm going to pass that adhesion there it
is right there okay and now I'm on the
two adhesion and that goes around
in
oh
don't don't reach
stay here our rim bring this adhesion so
this adhesion it's bringing him around
all you need it to do is come to this
adhesion there you touched it and now
the two
make that Circle so he's now going the
way that you want to enter
okay
all right uh
if I'm late and I'll figure it out so if
I'm late I'm gonna do my oshido 10 con
this would be a class
[Music]
boom
hump
around
is he going that way yet
no
so that's the class so he starts explore
That's The Clash that is so called in
that variation in Ikea you almost can't
see it okay so
his energy is full backwards you see I
have to spin it here
not stop it and make it go where it came
from
so it's going around
whoa
okay
try it